to look your your kids in the eye and to
tell them that you've been lying to them
you know I've never lied to my kids
about anything but I lied to them about
this so I told them I said I lied to you
guys you know and what I did was wrong
let me tell you what I've lied about I
have taken steroids I'm on steroids
right now and I can tell you the reasons
why I'm going to justify it you deserve
to know you know why I've Justified it
but what I did was wrong and I'll never
lie to you guys again and you know the
reason why I just the the mind is such a
deadly weapon because once I got myself
into this you know I convinced myself
that this had nothing to do with my
message I convinced myself that
um
who the [ __ ] am I cheating hmm like I'm
not in a competitive sport who am I
cheating you know and I would say like
one of the most hurtful things is um
or maybe I did some of the most damages
I convinced myself that the 15 year old
boy my kids these guys they don't need
to hear this message